[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to minecraft i was just
enjoying the music for a bit there
they've changed it it's
much more robust now i have not played
minecraft in a let's play fashion since
drunk minecraft part 69 which
was released in 2015. almost five years
ago
since the last time that i played
minecraft in a series
and today mark's cloaks collab with
minecraft for the release of minecraft
dungeons i thought about playing that
game
minecraft dungeons but i also realized
that
there's been so many changes to the game
so the last time i played
i don't even know there weren't bees in
the game
the point being is that today if you go
down in the description click on
the link to cloakbrand.com you can see
all of the cool designs
that we have collabed with mojang for
the release of minecraft dungeons
there's a ton of stuff down there i'm
wearing one of them right now i love
this pink
it's very nice there's a cool design on
the back too boom
so i'm going to play world
i feel like this isn't very important
but it might be important you never know
what's going to be important you never
know what's not going to be important i
don't know how good i'm going to do in
this
i'm going to text lisa and just tell me
actually i'm not even going to ask him
what it's what it's for
give me a random word
any minute now legs again while we're
waiting here are some designs
of the new cloak merch that's going to
be on cloakbrand.com
oh he's not getting back to me
oh no ah stuck at naming all right we're
just gonna have to
name it this is important it's important
it's important name
okay i'm asking wade hey can you give me
a random word
any word
where is everybody oh come on somebody
please why is nobody giving me a word
somebody give me a word i just want to
name it
i god i can't i'm crippled with
indecision i can't do it oh
gosh important that you need to pick a
one perfect
lixian got back to me pop
popsicle all right thank you alexia
thank you thank you thank you popsicle
spelled exactly that way it's not how i
would spell popsicle but maybe the
portuguese spell it slightly differently
all right
what okay uh pop cycle survival baby
i'm not gonna do any of this stuff
because i i don't want anything i want
the basic experience all right
so minor crisis is over
it's time to whoa that's weird i don't
know what's happening
i've never seen that before oh
great oh oh there it is
there she blows whoa turtle
wow horsies grass broken
bug i found a bug five years game's
broken
literally unplayable all right the music
might be just a little bit
too loud versus everything else i love
the music don't get me wrong i love the
music
but i just want it to be a very subtle
background note because i know that
there's some people that really don't
like the minecraft music
but that's not me i love the minecraft
music there's there's something very
magical about it there's there's
something that really completes the
experience
of minecraft in the music and i mean i i
couldn't explain to you what it is
exactly but i i just really like it i i
think it's extremely pleasant and i
think it's important to the experience
but that's just me all right so anyway
how do i
oh no no no no no sneak is control
sprint is shift anyone that says
otherwise
[Laughter]
all right back to the game that's much
better
also this auto jump thing what kind of
baby do they think i am
who are you i'm not playing on an ipid
i'm not playing on my
phone ah the field of view sorry hold on
hold on hold on all right now freaking
ages later you probably didn't know it
was ages later but ages later i'm
finally back into the game all right so
it all starts
the hell you saved me so it all starts
with this the basic experience
punching a log
shut up gummy log planks
i still remember baby i still remember
how i remember
i remember i remember nate i know that
all of you are gonna be like what a
scrub
what a loser what a nerd well you know
oh wait no
that's not right no that's yes and then
then i do this then i get the pickaxe
and then i
get the shh axe yes
yes yes and i used to have a very
specific
place on my keyboard that i would put
these things i don't remember what it is
exactly but i know i
i had one oh god the trees don't just
fall on their own which i think is real
dumb there was a mod
at some point i used to have like tons
of bots i used to play the modded
versions all the time like tekkit
and technic and trying to figure out
what the difference between them and
feed the beast and all that crap and
i don't know spruce spruce planks
does it matter is there a difference
there is a difference
but why why would there be a difference
i know
not for i am a simple idiot okay i think
i had that there
and then i had the sword as number four
that feels correct to me say you can go
back into my old way of playing
and tell me if this was actually what it
did oh i didn't have
stats here moist i mean poop
elixie and cut that out no cursing this
is family friendly censor it with
something uh
equally disturbing but not necessarily a
curse word okay
cool thanks thanks bud thanks pal thanks
dude
so i need to
start mining biaquis
it will be night and there will be
monsters and then i will be likely to do
the die
and if i do the die then i will not be
the do survive
wrecked that chicken capital r e
k t rec apostrophe d
wrecked i'm not gonna wax nostalgic this
whole time because probably
later on i'll be too busy screaming
about how i used to know how to play and
i'm an idiot right now but
i will say it is so strange to be number
one back
and number two doing like a solo let's
play
of this here's a little markiplier
history lesson for those of you who
don't know
i had a minecraft series a long time ago
but not on this channel not even on my
old channel
i had it on a channel that probably no
one to
this day still remembers it was called
markiplier 2 and it was
specifically my minecraft channel
not many people know about that but it
was a thing and i did it because i was
like i don't know if people want
minecraft
i don't know it's like i mean it was
still it was very popular when i when i
first started playing it but it was like
back then i was like well i don't know
if people want that
that kind of content on my channel now
i'll just i'll put whatever on my
channel i don't care it's
my channel's uh there is no rules as to
what goes on my channel but when it
comes down to
that stuff back then i was very much
just like well i just want to so
i dedic i made a whole channel just to
play minecraft on
woo spooky spooky dookie
all right i don't have many of these but
i think i see more
oh creepy yeah i'd definitely see more
are there gonna be monsters in here
no good hopefully this will be like a
home for me so i really i really don't
know what's
what's honestly all that difference am i
just gonna be like a hermit huddled up
in a cave because i don't actually know
how to play the game then i'm gonna be
dying
horribly and horribly in the middle of
the night i'm gonna be haunted by
the things that want to kill me of which
there are many in numerous amounts
may perhaps mayhaps that is my fate
who knows maybe i should make
cobblestone
tools is it stone tools or cobblestone
tools can you just make it out of
cobblestone does that count
i can't remember oh you can oh perfect
perfect good
i was almost an idiot for a second there
ah too bad i'm
far too smart for the likes of you i
just tried to make a stone shovel out of
a wooden shovel
oh
i did it i've done it and the last time
i played there wasn't even
achievements that's strange oh my
goodness look at this view
look at that view ooh let's make sure
i'm not crapping up a storm on the frame
right here
minecraft is so goddamn tough to
render all right how about that back
again there we go
oh now that is what i am talking about
did that crap down my
nah we're good baby we're good
okay
[Music]
i'm sorry all right cool ooh what is
this
all right i'll never know ooh what is it
daddy i forgot i mean poop flexing cut
it out family friendly
replace it with something equally
disturbing what is this marble
no oh no that's uh i i know what that is
that's the um
the the the you know the
yeah the stuff oh am i honestly getting
frame rate drops oh it's still the java
edition so i guess
man java just not efficient there we go
now that's nice buttery smooth
well not entirely this more coal i don't
need coal
i mean i'm gonna need coal because it's
about to get night and i'm gonna be
stuck in the forever dark but i don't
think i need that much coal i need iron
whoa weird right back when i play
back back in my day i never saw biomes
the likes of this before
this probably is not flabbergasted into
the laksa years
but to me's that's pretty impressive
that's cool
that's wicked wicked that's awesome
this is great i love this i really do
but all i'm seeing is coal so i'm not
sure how many things are going to be
exposed
so what i probably gotta do is i
probably disgust her
you think that you can come attack me
i think not try it try it you're stuck
in the water
idiot fool no no
thank you see you're dead and i'm not so
who's the idiot
who's the idiot i also always had that
there who's the idiot who's the idiot
dum-dum
that would be you it's getting dark ah
crap i don't have any shelter that's
fine
these babies don't even think that they
can hurt me
where did i go there's something all
right this is this has always been about
me there's something just very
viscerally
enjoyable about the breaking of blocks
in in minecraft
it's something that i always loved to do
i was never much of a builder
but i was always an excavator i was
always digging holes
i was that kid that was eating turds out
of the cat's sandbox
and digging holes i had nothing better
to do i knew no better oh
no oh no oh no oh
no no no no no no no
there is no need there's no need ah this
just goes down don't it
oh iron my first iron
i'm rich i'm rich thank you thank you i
deserve this
i deserve it i deserve this i deserve
all of this that is what some people
would call the good stuff
oh that's good yeah give me the
experience
oh that's nice it's so simple it it's
it's why i heart
heart it's why i harked off upon the
idea
that sound is incredibly important when
it comes to movies
games pretty much anything like if you
don't have the right sounds
the experience is never going to be the
same what is
iron no iron
iron irony roo
oh you're not iron kind of garbage is
this you're not iron at all
well this is some kind of baloney i am
going to starve
to death no no where
i left my crafting table i'm an idiot
yeah
it's fine i've got wood that's all that
a man needs
all right this is my base you like my
house guys
it's real good right all right furnace
if i remember
i do remember i remember i remember
you got proud of me i bet you are i bet
you are you're proud of me
oh my oh yeah it's working i was like
why aren't you doing you thing hello i
don't need to worry about that
get this coal just get this coal then i
bake that bread and then i make my money
and then i get
something else and then i kill the ender
dragon is that still the end of the game
i honestly have no idea if that's still
the end of the game because i know that
they put in the ender dragon and that
was like
the end and i know there's probably some
super deep
lore about the ender men and the end
people
and the en donios but i'm not
too up on the lore oh hell yeah
pickaxe baby give me that yes
yes yes this is the i know this is a
very strange thing to be excited about
but i am
i am tremendously excited about these
simple upgrades and i know that i seem
like
a baby's first minecraft experience but
hey give me
let me let me do what i come here to do
who is there why are they growling from
over here
why are you growling from here what is
over here
what is over here why is there so many
oh that don't sound right at all where
are they
there's so many why
oh iron thanks for leading me to the
iron i don't know
why rish british
fresh fresh fresh
big preachers all around thank you i
don't know why i'm going towards
but i'm just kind of curious to see
what's going on see i don't know i don't
know
what is different in this game versus
before probably not a whole lot
to be perfectly honest and they're gone
i don't hear them anymore
where'd they go this makes no sense
oh here they must be below
oh yeah well we're getting close baby
i don't know why i'm excited about that
but oh yeah
oh they're right here oh i'm in the
thick of it
oh yeah they're somewhere here
oh hello i found you
i found you i found you ah oh god
there's oh my god oh my god there's too
many
oh no no not like this not like this oh
i know what that was it was like a mob
spawner i've seen him before it's not
like it's been that long since i played
the game
but there were like 30 of them down
there
all right you know what it's fine at
least i didn't start a hardcore game
and hey i get to experience the night
it's beautiful out
it's lovely oh it's not lovely okay uh
hey hey how you doing
no no no no nope
nope nope nope nope nope
you're a lot tougher than i remember
hang on get back
get back get back get back
don't even think you're way way
infinitely tougher than i remember
why are you okay i did it i did the god
damn
the god damn god damn god damn it should
i go back and try to get
i guess i should right like i'm not i
had i it's not like i had a lot of good
stuff but it was all i had
i don't even remember where it was oh
how do i get there oh no
no this monster no please i don't want
anything thank you
oh thank you for your contribution to
the going away
thank you appreciate that oh boy oh god
don't please stop
that was a bit dumb oh god jim stop i
didn't
want to be a part of you i didn't want
to be any part of this oh god you're so
tough to kill please
there was a chest down there i need to
go get it just stop being
alive thank you
shut up shut up all of you at home shut
up
shut up just shut the [ __ ]
shut up [ __ ] [ __ ] stop laughing at me
shut up [ __ ] shut your mouth
i'll i'll find you i'll beat you up i'm
gonna cyber bully you if you
don't stop cyberbullying me i'm good at
games
i'm good i'm good at game it don't
matter what game i'm good at it
cause i i'm good i'm good at games i
think it was here it was here
yeah i was definitely here
my ankles ow
i don't remember fall damage being that
exorbitant
absorbance big word means a lot
excessive even okay
don't have enough this isn't a chest i
thought god i forgot
i don't know i'll give him my chicken
back
i'm gonna eat my chicken all right i ate
my chicken i didn't where are you
at hey
i didn't bring my table i'm gonna get
you
no this isn't the right way to help help
somebody else i'm not
helpless baby help okay table here we go
boink and then
don't do it i'm gonna get you guys
you're gonna see you're gonna see you're
gonna see today
bullies all right i'm not gonna drop
down there
that would be dumb i won't do that
cause i ain't the dumb all right we're
gonna
we're gonna do that we're gonna dance
baby we're gonna dance yeah yeah dance
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah get
gone
yeah what happened to like the 13 of you
there were like 300 000 of you guys
can you any minute oh god no please i
want my corpse
oh you suck this game is much harder
than a no
don't spawn you don't want to do that
[Music]
you're believing me
i'm being bullied oh they can't reach me
oh i was fine i didn't have to actually
hit him
oh look at that golden
golden horse armor wow rotten flesh
huh where where did i die hey you guys
suck i got gold horse armor i'm gonna
i'm gonna horse it up
you guys don't know you gave me the
destiny of which i knew i was
supposed to have where is my stuff
my stuff isn't there no no no
no no no go away
go away i'll beat you with the horse
armor i'll do it
go away oh there's another chest oh my
stuff is gone
go away go away
you all suck and i hate you i'm gonna
run out of pickaxe can you
shut up for two seconds you loud
jerk bags that's an ordeal everybody but
i i know that what's gonna be in this
other chest is gonna be totally worth it
no do not this this will not let the
okay
perfect get it get get it get it gone
gone go i'm gone baby gone
iron horse armor perfect perfect
it's perfect go away go away i hate you
i hate you all so much why did i go down
there
oh every part of my life every
everything everything my whole life
just has been leading up to this moment
i have horse armor
and bread i got this bread
guys i did it i got this bread i got
this bread
i got the bread i did it i did it i got
the bread
it's a good day it's good it's a good
day i think that's a good place to stop
i got the bread
then i got the horse armor the two
things that i wanted to get
now i just got to figure out how to put
it on a horse so thank you everybody so
much for watching
it it is uh it's strange to be back it
really is strange to be back
i i think i'm gonna keep playing i think
i will i think i'm gonna keep doing more
episodes of this at least for a little
bit i'm not gonna do like a long long
series but i just uh
you know there's a world to explore and
it's kind of fun so thank you everybody
so much for watching remember you can
check out the new cloak collection
collabing with minecraft down in the
description cloakbrand.com that's
c-l-o-a-k-b-r-a-n-d.com
thank you lixian for the assist on that
one and for making me not look like an
idiot this episode right
i bet i look good and smart
and brave and fashionable
in my new shirt oh and before i go if
you want to check out and you don't know
about it i have an entire series on
minecraft called drunk minecraft that i
did with bob and wade
it goes back to the very beginning of
this channel's history so if you want to
go uh have a blast from the past
just look in the description for a
playlist of the entire drunk minecraft
series also in the end cards after i'm
done talking and i say bye bye
there will be a card that you can click
on that'll take you to the whole
playlist 69 episodes
wink thanks again and as always i will
see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you